Esiste un segnale nascosto che le donne
percepiscono ancor prima che tu apra
bocca e la maggior parte degli uomini
trascorrerà tutta la vita completamente
ignara della sua esistenza. Quello che
sto per condividere con voi non ha
assolutamente nulla a che fare con la
vostra altezza, il vostro conto in banca
o quanti capelli avete ancora in testa.
Si tratta del linguaggio invisibile che
il vostro corpo trasmette ogni singolo
secondo di ogni giorno e di come
comprenderlo possa cambiare quasi
immediatamente il modo in cui le donne
vi percepiscono.
Non dopo anni di lavoro su voi stessi,
non dopo una trasformazione drastica,
quasi immediatamente.
Ma prima di iniziare, un piccolo favore,
mettete un like a questo video e fatemi
sapere nei commenti da quale città o
paese vi collegate oggi.
Leggo sempre i commenti e mi piace molto
vedere come la community di psicologia
femminile continua a crescere. Ora ecco
qualcosa che alla maggior parte degli
uomini non è mai stato insegnato.
L'aspetto fisico rappresenta solo una
parte dell'equazione dell'attrazione.
Il resto, e questa è la parte più
consistente, si basa su segnali
psicologici innati e questi segnali, a
differenza del viso, possono essere
assolutamente allenati e calibrati. È
proprio di questo che parleremo in
questo video. Ho dedicato anni allo
studio della psicologia comportamentale,
della scienza dell'attrazione e dei
segnali non verbali che determinano come
veniamo percepiti dagli altri.
Ciò che emerge costantemente è questo:
una volta che un uomo inizia a inviare i
segnali giusti, le donne lo
descriveranno come più attraente di
quanto non fosse il giorno prima, anche
quando il suo aspetto non è cambiato
assolutamente nulla. L'avete già visto,
vero?
Un uomo nella stanza che sulla carta non
sembra avere nulla di eccezionale,
un aspetto nella media, un abbigliamento
ordinario. Eppure una donna pende dalle
sue labbra, ride, si avvicina, ha gli
occhi che le brillano. Nel frattempo voi
siete lì vicino con un guardaroba più
curato e un curriculum migliore e
pensate cosha lui che io non ho. Non è
magia, non è fortuna. Sono segnali e
oggi vi illustrerò 10 dei più potenti.
Uno, l'ancora percettiva. Il cervello
umano non elabora tutto ciò che vede,
prende delle scorciatoie.
Nel momento in cui percepisce un segnale
di alto status, presume automaticamente
che adesso si assomigli tutta una serie
di altre caratteristiche positive.
Questo meccanismo è chiamato effetto
alone e la postura è uno dei suoi più
rapidi fattori scatenanti.
Ecco cosa succede fisicamente.
Quando il petto è aperto e la colonna
vertebrale è allineata, i livelli di
ormoni dello stress si abbassano e la
percezione della propria presenza
aumenta. Entrate in una stanza con
questo atteggiamento, mento all'altezza
della testa, spalle indietro, petto
aperto e il subconscio della persona che
vi circonda
vi attribuirà già un'etichetta di alto
valore, prima ancora che abbiate
pronunciato una sola parola. Ho visto
uomini apparire letteralmente più alti
agli occhi degli altri, semplicemente
cambiando il loro portamento. La postura
è il mezzo di comunicazione non verbale
più veloce che avete. Usatela. Du lo
sguardo calibrato.
La maggior parte degli uomini gestisce
il contatto visivo in uno di questi due
modi sbagliati
o fissano con troppa intensità un tipo
di sguardo che viene percepito come
minaccioso o disperato, oppure
distolgono lo sguardo non appena si
incrociano, il che viene interpretato
come vergogna o insicurezza.
La mossa giusta è qualcosa di
intermedio. Mantieni il contatto visivo
per circa un secondo, poi fai un cenno
molto discreto o un mezzo sorriso
silenzioso
e distogli lo sguardo di tua spontanea
volontà. Sei tu che hai iniziato a
interrompere il contatto.
Questo comunica al suo cervello qualcosa
di silenzioso ma potente. L'hai notata,
non sei agitato e non sei avido della
sua attenzione.
Questa sequenza crea una micro scintilla
di curiosità che rimane.
Una volta che la curiosità è stata
piantata, lei inizia a colmare le lacune
completamente da sola.
Tre. Il segnale lampeggiante.
Può sembrare strano la prima volta che
lo senti, ma una volta che ci fai caso
lo noterai ovunque.
Una persona nervosa o sopraffatta sbatte
le palpebre rapidamente.
Una persona che si sente completamente a
suo agio nel proprio ambiente sbatte le
palpebre lentamente e con calma.
Inizia ad allenare una frequenza di
sbattimento delle palpebre più
tranquilla, leggermente più lenta di
quella che ti sembra normale.
Le donne percepiscono questo movimento a
livello inconscio. Quando le palpebre si
muovono con calma e regolarità,
comunicano che il tuo sistema nervoso è
regolato, che appartiene al luogo in cui
ti trovi, che nulla intorno a te
rappresenta una minaccia.
4. Il calo di ritmo. Un uomo ansioso
parla velocemente,
accelera il suo discorso perché da
qualche parte nel suo sistema nervoso,
sente di avere poco tempo a
disposizione, come se dovesse dimostrare
il suo punto di vista prima di essere
interrotto, ma l'energia di un uomo
sicuro di sé si muove lentamente e con
consapevolezza.
Provate a rallentare il vostro ritmo di
eloquio anche solo del 10% rispetto a
quello che vi sembra naturale. Qualcosa
cambia.
La vostra voce si fa leggermente più
profonda, più calda e le persone trovano
effettivamente ciò che dite più
convincente.
Le donne hanno costantemente descritto
gli uomini che parlano più lentamente
come più calmi, più affidabili, più
equilibrati,
pur non sapendo spiegare esattamente il
perché.
Una voce calma ha più peso di una voce
alta.
5. Il pubblico invisibile.
Ecco qualcosa che cambierà
silenziosamente il tuo modo di
rapportarti al mondo.
Nessuno là fuori sta studiando i tuoi
difetti con la stessa intensità con cui
lo fai tu.
Quell'attaccatura dei capelli che si
allarga e che tieni d'occhio da 3 anni.
Lei non se n'è ancora accorta.
Il peso in eccesso che ti porti dietro
dall'inverno
non è sulla sua testa.
Il cambiamento avviene nel momento in
cui smetti di compensare, smetti di
tirarti la maglietta, smetti di
inclinare la testa per nascondere un
difetto, smetti di fare invisibili
autocorrezioni.
Nell'istante in cui smetti di
nasconderti,
ciò che stavi nascondendo praticamente
scompare.
Ho visto uomini sulla cinquantina
reinventare completamente la propria
immagine, semplicemente decidendo di
smettere di scusarsi per il loro
aspetto.
Se silenzio strategico.
La maggior parte degli uomini è stata
condizionata a credere che il silenzio
in una conversazione sia un segnale di
fallimento,
quindi si affrettano a riempirlo,
aggiungono dettagli superflui. si
dilungano troppo, iniziano a recitare.
Il problema è che più un uomo recita,
meno sicuro di sé appare in realtà.
Ecco la verità psicologica che cambia
tutto. Il silenzio non è scomodo quando
si è calmi e sicuri di sé, lo è solo
quando si è nervosi.
E quando la tensione si accumula nello
spazio tra le parole, quella tensione,
se gestita con calma, genera
effettivamente attrazione.
La regolazione emotiva è una delle
qualità più rare e magnetiche che un
uomo possa dimostrare.
Pensate agli uomini che conoscete e che
emanano una più tranquilla
autorevolezza.
Non si affannano mai a riempire un
vuoto. Quella compostezza è
intenzionale.
Prova così, di qualcosa di veramente
significativo,
poi resta in silenzio. Non addolcire la
voce.
Non cercare di provocare una sua
reazione, mantieni semplicemente il
silenzio.
Ti sorprenderà quanto spesso si sporgerà
per riempire quello spazio e quella
sporgenza è segno di interesse.
7. La cornice senza fretta.
Un uomo che sembra di fretta sta
comunicando qualcosa che lo voglia o no,
che non si sente del tutto sicuro di sé.
La velocità è indice di ansia.
Quando ti muovi rapidamente durante le
interazioni, scruti la stanza mentre lei
parla o prendi il telefono a metà
conversazione, comunichi assenza
e le donne percepiscono la presenza
emotiva con straordinaria sensibilità.
Il cambiamento è semplice. Rallenta un
po' tutto. Prendi il bicchiere
lentamente. Gira la testa con un
movimento fluido e deciso. Quando ti
siedi assumi una postura rilassata, come
se avessi tutto il tempo del mondo.
Questa disinvoltura comunica sicurezza
senza bisogno di parole.
8. La voce dichiarativa.
La vera sicurezza in se stessi non si
manifesta a gran voce, ma arriva
silenziosamente attraverso le
affermazioni.
L'abitudine da eliminare è quella di
terminare le frasi con un tono
ascendente, come se si avesse bisogno di
una conferma da parte di qualcun altro.
Ultimamente mi dedico molto al fitness.
Pronunciato con un'inflessione
ascendente, suona come se si stesse
chiedendo il permesso.
Ultimamente mi dedico molto al fitness.
Pronunciato con un tono piatto e
uniforme trasmette la sensazione di una
persona che semplicemente si conosce.
Questa piccola differenza di tono, per
quanto sottile, distingue la leadership
dalla ricerca di approvazione.
Scegliete di essere leader.
L'uomo che non ha bisogno di
approvazione sembra sempre averla.
Il calore controllato.
Ci sono due modi fallimentari di
sorridere. Il primo è sorridere
costantemente e con entusiasmo, il che
dà l'impressione di sforzarsi troppo per
piacere.
Il secondo è non sorridere mai. Il che
appare freddo o chiuso, nessuno dei due
funziona. Ciò che funziona davvero è il
microsorriso.
Breve, controllato, genuino.
Appare, comunica serenità e svanisce
naturalmente.
Trasmette calore senza disperazione,
sicurezza senza freddezza.
L'attrazione fisica può aprire le porte,
ma se una donna non si sente
emotivamente al sicuro con la tua
energia, non le varcherà. Deve percepire
che stare con te non le costa nulla. Il
microsorriso le comunica calma e la
calma è contagiosa. T E n presenza
spaziale.
Le persone di alto livello occupano lo
spazio, non in modo aggressivo, ma con
naturalezza.
Gli uomini che si sentono a disagio in
una stanza si rimpiccioliscono,
incrociano le braccia, incurvano le
spalle, tengono le gambe unite e si
rannicchiano nella versione più piccola
possibile del loro corpo. La soluzione è
semplice. Occupate il 10% di spazio in
più. Lasciate che le braccia siano
rilassate lungo i fianchi. Tenete i
piedi alla larghezza delle spalle.
Mantenete le spalle aperte e indietro.
Non state dominando la stanza. Vi state
semplicemente muovendo al suo interno,
come qualcuno che ci appartiene.
Il suo subconscio percepisce questo
segnale prima ancora che abbiate
pronunciato una sola sillaba.
Nessuno di questi 10 segnali ti impone
di diventare una persona diversa.
Nessuno di essi richiede una
performance.
Anzi, la performance è il nemico. Quando
elimini le abitudini ansiose, la fretta,
le spiegazioni eccessive, la tendenza a
rimpicciolirti,
ciò che rimane è una versione di te che
è sempre esistita.
Questa versione non ha bisogno di essere
costruita da zero, ha solo bisogno di
smettere di essere soffocata.
Ecco cosa vorrei che vi rimanesse
impresso dopo aver visto questo video.
L'uomo che ha smesso di aver bisogno di
essere scelto diventa l'uomo che
sceglie.
Questo cambiamento interiore è qualcosa
che le donne percepiscono nel momento
stesso in cui entrate in una stanza.
Non ha bisogno di annunciarsi,
semplicemente arriva e quando arriva
l'intera dinamica cambia.
Se questo ti ha dato qualcosa di
concreto oggi, clicca Mi piacie e
sostieni la psicologia femminile e
lascia un commento qui sotto dicendomi
quale di questi 10 segnali ti ha colpito
di più. Leggo tutti i commenti.